that sort of statement like hey if
you're active and have decent body comp
like this nutrition principle for health
doesn't really apply to you sometimes
that is true um so for example we've
talked about this on the podcast before
uh some people are concerned about high
sugar intake or high fructose intake in
particular
and i mean as far as that goes like to
simplify
a relatively large body of literature um
there might be something to that like if
you're
relatively sedentary and consuming a lot
of sugar there might be some some
negative downstream effects of that but
if you are
quite active have relatively high sugar
intake especially if you're also in a
calorie deficit
it seems like it just doesn't matter so
there are there are such certain
situations where
a nutrition recommendation with with
health in mind does apply to one
population and doesn't apply to another
population
um i also think
that one of the things motivating this
this type of fault
is sometimes just to kind of like get
oneself off the hook for a way that you
have to eat in pursuit of some other
goal so for example um
you know if someone is a crossfit
athlete or an endurance athlete or even
just like a super heavyweight power
lifter or strong man and in order to
fuel your performance and and just
maintain weight um if you're trying to
get down five six thousand calories per
day
that's going to be pretty hard to do if
you're trying to eat like quote unquote
clean
and so
imagine trying to do that on a low sugar
low sodium diet insane yeah i ca i can't
even conceive of that no um
and i don't think most people can
conceive of that and so you know i think
that uh people who primarily have
performance goals might want to tell
themselves like look
i gotta do what i gotta do to get down
this many calories uh performance is
very important to me this is how i have
to eat to fuel my performance
uh and so
i'm just going to assume that this is
all fine uh like i think that there i
think that there's some amount of that
uh in play
um
i also think it is true to some extent
that
some of the specific benefits that one
might get from eating
like quote unquote healthy foods
are also benefits that one would get
from exercise so for example uh there
are plenty of benefits from eating
antioxidant rich fruits
and and we kind of joked about uh uh
paul saladino being afraid of vegetables
and and defense chemicals and vegetables
uh last episode so like it is true that
there are chemicals and vegetables that
are like trying to kill things that are
eating them we are big enough that those
chemicals don't kill us but they do
cause some amount of oxidative stress
and one of the reasons vegetables are
good for you is that your body responds
to that stressor of the vegetable by
increasing endogenous antioxidant levels
endogenous antioxidant activity so that
that that's one of the i think that's a
very cool thing about vegetables that's
one of the reasons they're good for you
in addition to like fiber intake and
phytonutrients and other stuff um but
yeah so
you know those are those are discrete
benefits of two
categories of food that are typically
thought to be very good for you those
are also benefits you get from exercise
so when you exercise that causes
oxidative stress and as a result your
body's endogenous antioxidant system
produces more antioxidants the activity
of those antioxidants increases so
there there's
you know i i do think that it's still
probably an additive benefit like
exercising and eating vegetables
probably better than exercising and not
eating vegetables but if you exercise
and eat vegetables there there are a lot
of similar things going on on a cellular
level that you would see in someone who
doesn't exercise and does eat vegetables
like it you're causing similar
physiological effects maybe making
vegetable intake slightly less important
still important still good for you but
you you are already getting some of
those same adaptations just from doing
exercise so i think that's a dynamic
as well
and there's also kind of a
similar situation where sometimes
exercise
is directly attenuating some of the
potentially deleterious impacts of a
food so also true yeah one of the things
that came up was like sodium and and i
think about like
an endurance runner who is
running like crazy uh which you know be
having high cardio respiratory fitness
generally tends to to drive blood
pressure downward and they're just
sweating out a ton of sodium during
their you know runs in the summer and
things like that so
you can see where for that individual
there are directly protective mechanisms
in place that counteract the the kind of
primary thing you'd be concerned about
which would be the sodium in increasing
blood pressure yeah yeah so there there
is
to to some extent the the things that
people are the the the
sorts of statements that this uh uh
question comment was responding to
sometimes it's just true so in the case
of sugar intake sometimes uh you know it
would still be good to eat healthy
things but
you you get yourself off the hook a
little bit because you're you are
causing similar physiological
adaptations from doing exercise uh
however there is a very large kernel of
truth to what uh what you expect was
asking here on reddit um and i think
that a lot of times
when people either say uh you know hey
you don't have to worry about this
nutrition advice for health because
you're exercising or they tell
themselves that like yeah you know what
i'm i'm healthy i'm exercising i don't
need to worry about this stuff all that
much
i think that i think that implicitly
what people are often doing
is comparing risk levels between
populations and they kind of have
implicitly a population in mind where
they say okay this population is at an
elevated risk and i consider this level
of elevated risk to be too much so as
long as what i'm doing keeps me below
that level of risk i am therefore good
so for example
the comment mentioned saturated fat
intake and so you know if you're pretty
active and you consume a decent amount
of saturated fat your risk of
cardiovascular disease
is probably lower than someone who is
sedentary and consumes the same amount
of saturated fat and it may be
comparable to someone who's sedentary
and consumes very little saturated fat
and so you look at that and you say well
okay i'm comfortable with the level of
risk of being sedentary and consuming
low saturated fat i am active therefore
i can consume a fair bit of saturated
fat and not be at
elevated risk relative to
the level of risk i am comfortable with
so you might be able to lower your risk
even more if you are quite active and
consumed very low saturated fat but just
kind of what what you're implicitly
pegging your brain to uh in terms of
what you perceive to be
risk you're comfortable with versus
uncomfortable with you know the the way
you're eating given your activity levels
still keeps you below that level of risk
that you're comfortable with even though
you could probably reduce your risk
further if you wanted to